RIGHTS WILL BE CONTINGENT ON
SAYING THE RIGHT THINGS?
TO FIND OUT WE HAVE INVITED
KEVIN PARKER ON THE SHOW
TONIGHT FROM BROOKLYN YOU
JUST SAW ON THAT TAPE.
SENATOR PARKER, THANKS FOR
COMING ON TONIGHT.
>> THANKS FOR HAVING ME ON,
TUCKER.
>> Tucker: I SHOULD SAY AT
THE OUTSET WHICH I'M SURE
VIEWERS ALREADY KNOW IT'S
ALREADY AGAINST FEDERAL LAW
TO SELL FIREARMS TO THE
MENTALLY ILL, THANK HEAVEN
AND I THINK ALL OF US
SUPPORT THAT RESTRICTION.
SO IT'S ALREADY AGAINST THE
LAW.
BUT, WHAT OTHER
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS THAT
WE AS AMERICANS POSSESS
SHOULD BE CONTINGENT ON HOW
WE BEHAVE ON SOCIAL MEDIA?
>> WELL, LET'S BE CLEAR, I
TAKE AN OATH THAT SUPPORTS
THE AMENDMENTS AND THE WHOLE
CONSTITUTION BOTH THE U.S.
AND THE STATE GOVERNMENT
CONSTITUTION.
>> Tucker: RIGHT.
>> THIS IS REALLY NOT
IMPINGING ON CONSTITUTIONAL
RIGHTS.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT SAFETY.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT HOW DO
WE, IN FACT, MAKE THE STATE
OF NEW YORK AS SAFE AS
POSSIBLE?
NOW, WE HAVE ALREADY BEEN
VERY SAFE.
ONE OF THE TOP THREE SAFEST
STATES IN THE ENTIRE
COUNTRY, PARTICULARLY WHEN
YOU LOOK AT, YOU KNOW MASS
SHOOTINGS, THANK GOD.
BUT, WE CAN ALWAYS BE SAFER
AND WE CAN ALWAYS MAKE SURE
THAT WHAT HAPPENS IN
PITTSBURGH, WHAT WE SAW IN
PARKLAND, WHAT WE SAW IN
ORLANDO DOESN'T HAPPEN HERE.
AND SO THIS LAW SIMPLY SAYS
LET'S LOOK AT, YOU KNOW,
WHAT PEOPLE ARE PUTTING OUT
ON SOCIAL MEDIA AS A, YOU
KNOW, PART OF A SET OF
CRITERIA THAT WE'RE USING TO
DETERMINE WHO GETS HAND
GUNS.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON AND BY
THE WAY, I AGREE WITH YOUR
DESIRE TO MAKE YOUR STATE
AND EVERY STATE AS SAFE AS
WE POSSIBLY CAN.
BUT WHY RESTRICT IT TO GUN
OWNERS?
YOU ARE AN ELECTED OFFICIAL.
YOU ARE A STATE SENATOR.
YOU WE WOULD A LOT
YOU WIEWOULD A LOT
YOU WIELDULD A LOT
YOU WIELD AD A LOT
YOU WIELD A LA LOT
YOU WIELD A LOTLOT
YOU WIELD A LOT OT
YOU WIELD A LOT OF POWER.
YOU CONTROL PEOPLE'S LIVES.
WHY SHOULDN'T I HAVE THE
PASSWORD TO YOUR SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNT TO ASSESS
WHETHER YOU SHOULD BE
WIELDING THE POWER YOU
SHOULD DO.
>> MAYBE SHOULD PUT THAT LAW
IN AND MAYBE WE CAN DO THAT.
>> Tucker: NO.
IT'S A FAIR QUESTION.
WOULD YOU SEND ME YOUR
PASSWORD?
>> TUCKER, MY SOCIAL MEDIA
IS OPEN RIGHT NOW.
CAN YOU GO ON IT AND LOOK AT
IT ANYBODY CAN LOOK AT IT.
IT'S PUBLIC INFORMATION.
>> Tucker: I DON'T KNOW.
HOLD ON, WHY DON'T YOU SEND
ME YOUR PASSWORDS AND FIND
OUT HOW OPEN IT REALLY IS
YOU ARE REQUIRING GUN OWNERS
TO GIVE YOU THEIR PASSWORDS.
WHY SHOULDN'T THEY TURN
AROUND AND ASK YOU FOR THE
SAME?
THAT'S A SINCERE QUESTION.
>> LOOK, WHAT WE SHOULD BE
TALKING ABOUT IS HOW DO WE
MAKE THE STATE OF NEW YORK
SAFE?
I'M SIMPLY SAYING RIGHT NOW
WE'RE NOT AS SAFE AS WE CAN
BE BECAUSE PEOPLE ARE SAYING
THINGS ON SOCIAL MEDIA AND
WE'RE NOT USING THAT AND
LOOKING AT THAT AS WE, IN
FACT, GIVE OUT A WEAPON THAT
CAN USED TO KILL PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I GET WHAT YOU
ARE SAYING.
I GUESS I'M JUST WONDERING
WHY WE ARE RESTRICTING.
I MEAN AS LONG AS -- YOU
SAID PRIVACY IS NOT A
CONCERN.
IF YOU HAVE CONCERNS ABOUT
PRIVACY DON'T CARRY A GUN.
DON'T BUY A GUN.
OKAY.
BUT YOU ARE SAYING THAT
THAT'S THE ONLY CATEGORY TO
WHICH THIS APPLIES.
WHY DON'T WE APPLY IT TO
VOTING.
BEFORE YOU VOTE AND CHOOSE
WHO RUNS THE STATE, WHO
CONTROLS YOUR LIFE, WHY
SHOULDN'T YOU HAVE YOUR
SOCIAL MEDIA CHECKED?
I'M NOT SURE I UNDERSTAND.
>> BECAUSE VOTING DOESN'T
NECESSARILY LEAD TO PEOPLE
KILLING EACH OTHER.
THIS IS REALLY ABOUT ACCESS
TO GUNS.
THIS IS ABOUT ACCESS TO GUNS
AND WE KNOW THERE IS A
DIRECT CORRELATION WITH THE
NUMBER OF GUNS THAT ARE
AVAILABLE IN STATES AND THE
PREVALENCE OF MASS
SHOOTINGS.
>> Tucker: WE DON'T KNOW.
I'M SORRY, JUST THAT'S
ACTUALLY -- THAT'S NOT TRUE.
I THINK WYOMING HAS THE
HIGHEST PER CAPITA GUN
OWNERSHIP IN THE COUNTRY.
I DON'T THINK THERE ARE ANY
MASS SHOOTINGS.
>> WITH THE FIVE PEOPLE WHO
LIVE IN WYOMING AND THE GUNS
THEY HAVE.
>> Tucker: THERE IS NOT A
CORRELATION BETWEEN THOSE
TWO THINGS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
THERE IS ABSOLUTELY.
TUCKER, THERE ABSOLUTELY IS.
WHEN WE LOOK AT PLACES LIKE
JAPAN AND LOOK AT PLACES
LIKE AUSTRALIA, THEY HAVE
MUCH LOWER GUN VIOLENCE AND
MASS SHOOTINGS.
>> Tucker: THE QUESTION
HERE.
>> THEY LIMIT THE NUMBER OF
GUNS THAT PEOPLE HAVE.
>> Tucker: YOU ARE NOT
CALLING FOR LIMITING THE
NUMBER OF GUNS IN THIS BILL.
YOU ARE CALLING FOR PEOPLE
TO TURN OVER SOCIAL MEDIA
PASSWORDS SO YOU CAN DECIDE
WHETHER THEY HAVE SAID
THINGS THAT ARE NAUGHTY AND
IF THEY HAVE, THEY DON'T GET
TO OWN A GUN.
AND SO MY QUESTION IS WHAT
OTHER CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHTS
ARE DEPENDENT ON YOUR
APPROVAL?
IS THE RIGHT TO ABORTION?
SHOULD WE BEFORE ALLOWING
WOMEN TO HAVE ABORTIONS
CHECK THEIR SOCIAL MEDIA
ACCOUNTS?
THIS IS A SIP SEAR QUESTION?
IF NOT?
WHY NOT?
>> TUCKER, I'M REALLY
FOCUSING ON THE ISSUE OF GUN
VIOLENCE.
THERE IS TOO MUCH GUN
VIOLENCE IN OUR COMMUNITIES.
TOO MUCH GUN VIOLENCE ACROSS
THE COUNTRY.
>> Tucker: I AGREE I'M
AGAINST GUN VIOLENCE.
>> WE NEED TO GET IT DOWN.
>> Tucker: HOLD ON.
WHO IS GOING TO MAKE THIS
DID.
>> THE NEW YORK STATE
POLICE.
>> Tucker: BUT THEY WILL
JUST DECIDE -- TYPICALLY
BEFORE WE DETERMINE SOMEONE
IS MENTALLY ILL WE
ADJUDICATE THAT PERSON
MENTALLY ILL.
>> THIS IS NOT ABOUT MENTAL
ILLNESS.
>> Tucker: WHAT IS IT ABOUT?
>> IN ADDITION TO THE OTHER
CRITERIA THAT THE NEW YORK
STATE POLICE WILL USE AND
THEY ALREADY USE TO
DETERMINE WHO SHOULD BE
ELIGIBLE TO GET A GUN
PERMIT, IN ADDITION TO THAT
WHAT I'M SAY SOMETHING WE
SHOULD ALSO HAVE THE STATE
POLICE REVIEW THE SOCIAL
MEDIA ACCOUNTS OF THE PEOPLE
WHO ARE MAKING THE REQUESTS.
YOU CAN.
>> Tucker: AND TAKE
PASSWORDS.
WHAT WOULD CAUSE STATE
POLICE, INDEPENDENT OF A
JUDGE, GET TO DECIDE WHETHER
YOU CAN HAVE A GUN OR NOT
BASED ON WHETHER OR NOT THEY
LIKE WHAT YOU SAID ON
FACEBOOK?
>> THE STATE LEGISLATURE HAS
THE ABILITY, WITH THE
SIGNATURE OF THE GOVERNOR,
TO, IN FACT, MAKE LAW.
AND SO WE MAKE IT THE LAW.
WE THEN CAN, IN FACT,
SUBSCRIBE.
TURN OVER POWER TO THE STATE
POLICE AND THEY MAKE A
DETERMINATION WHICH THEY DO
YOU WILL AT TIME BY THE WAY.
>> Tucker: THE POLICE GET TO
UNILATERALLY DECIDE WHETHER
WE CAN EXERCISE OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL RIGHT?
YOU ARE COMFORTABLE GIVING
POLICE THAT POWER.
>> THE STATE LEGISLATURE IS
DECIDING IT.
>> Tucker: NO STATE
LEGISLATURE IS HANDING OVER
TO THEM THE POWER TO DECIDE.
>> EXACTLY.
>> Tucker: OH, NO, EXACTLY,
RIGHT?
>> BUT THEY ALREADY HAVE
THAT POWER RIGHT NOW AT THIS
VERY MOMENT THE STATE POLICE
DECIDES WHO GETS A GUN AND
WHO DOESN'T GET A GUN.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IT'S
A LITTLE INTRUSIVE THAT THE
GOVERNMENT WOULD BE FORCING
CITIZENS TO TURN OVER THEIR
SOCIAL MEDIA PASSWORDS TO
THE POLICE BEFORE DOING
SOMETHING THE CONSTITUTION
GUARANTEES THEM THE RIGHT
TO?
THAT DOESN'T BOTHER YOU IN
ANY WAY?
DOESN'T SEEM A LITTLE BIT
TOTALITARIAN OR SOMETHING
MAYBE CHINA WOULD DO?
>> TUCKER, WE MAKE
LEGISLATION THROUGH A
PROCESS.
ALL THE THINGS THAT YOU HAVE
OBJECTED TO, THERE ARE LOTS
OF PEOPLE WHO OBJECT TO IT.
THERE ARE CONVERSATIONS
GOING ON.
>> Tucker: I CAN'T LET YOU
SKIRT THE THIRD QUESTION.
DO YOU THINK IT'S A LITTLE
BIT --
>> -- NO I'M NOT WHAT I'M
SAYING TO YOU.
>> Tucker: I'M AWARE HAD HOW
OUR GOVERNMENT WORKS.
>> AN OPPORTUNITY FOR US TO
WORK TOGETHER TO, IN FACT,
LOOK AT THIS.
MAYBE THE PASSWORD --
>> Tucker: THESE ARE YOUR
BILLS AND YOUR PROPOSALS.
SOMETHING THAT YOU CAME UP
WITH.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
>> Tucker: I'M JUST ASKING
YOU AS YOU SAT AT YOUR
LAPTOP AND TYPED OUT YOU
WILL BE REQUIRED TO HAND
OVER YOUR PASSWORDS TO THE
STATE POLICE AND IF THEY
DON'T LIKE WHAT YOU SAY YOU
DON'T GET TO EXERCISE YOUR
RIGHT.
DON'T YOU THINK THAT SOUNDS
A LITTLE ORWELLIAN TO ME.
REALLY?
YOU ARE GOING TO DO THAT.
>> FOCUSING ON A PART THAT
QUITE NOT REALLY THE WHOLE
BILL, RIGHT IN THE BIG THING
IS.
>> Tucker: OTHER THAN THAT,
MRS. LINCOLN, HOW WAS THE
PLAY?
IT'S NOT THE WHOLE BILL.
>> IT'S NOT THE WHOLE BILL
BUT IT'S PART OF IT.
>> Tucker: IT'S PART OF IT
AND YOU DON'T SEE THAT AS
FASCIST IN ANY WAY?
SHOULD THE STATE POLICE HAVE
TO SIGN OFF ON YOUR MARRIAGE
DO YOU THINK OR HOW MANY
KIDS YOU COULD HAVE?
BECAUSE OBVIOUSLY SOME
PEOPLE SHOULDN'T BE GETTING
MARRIED.
>> RIGHT.
AGAIN, WHAT WE'RE CONCERNED
ABOUT IS THE SAFETY OF THE
PEOPLE IN THE STATE OF NEW
YORK.
AND WE'RE CONCERNED THAT
PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: I'M NOT GOING TO
MOVE YOU FROM YOUR TALKING
POINT.
I'M NOT GOING TO GET TO YOU
THINK CRITICALLY ABOUT THIS,
OBVIOUSLY.
>> NO, WHAT I'M DOING IS
TALKING ABOUT THE VALUES.
AND I GET THAT SOME PEOPLE.
>> Tucker: WHAT YOU ARE
DOING IS SCARING ME.
>> HAVING A GUN IS MORE
IMPORTANT THAN PROTECTING
THE LIVES OF STRANGERS.
>> Tucker: NO BE ABLE TO SAY
CONTROVERSIAL THINGS ONLINE.
LAST QUESTION DO YOU THINK
PEOPLE HAVE A RIGHT TO SAY
OUTRAGEOUS THINGS IN PUBLIC?
>> THEY CERTAINLY CAN SAY
WHATEVER THEY WANTS TO SAY.
>> Tucker: BUT THEN YOU
PUNISH THEM FOR SAYING THAT.
>> WE ALSO HAVE THE RIGHT TO
DENY THEM A GUN PERMIT IF WE
BELIEVE THAT THE THINGS THEY
ARE SAYING MAY LEAD TO THEM
ENDANGERING THE PEOPLE OF
THE STATE OF NEW YORK.
>> Tucker: MAY OR MAY NOT.
>> FRANKLY, THE SUPREME
COURT HAS ALREADY SAID THAT.
>> Tucker: SAY SOMETHING
NAUGHTY --
>> -- FOR INSTANCE, WE LIMIT
PEACH ALL THE TIME LIKE
PORNOGRAPHY, PARTICULARLY
CHILD PORNOGRAPHY, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: CHILD PORNOGRAPHY
HAS NOT BEEN RULED TO BE
SPEECH I WOULD REFER TO YOU
BRANDON VS. OHIO IN 1967
WHICH IS THE FINAL WORD ON
SPEECH FROM THE SUPREME
COURT SINCE YOU ARE
INTERESTED AND ALLOWS ALL
SPEECH EXCEPT SPEECHES THAT
CALLS FOR IMMINENT VIOLENCE
ALL SPEECH.
>> LIKE GETTING A GUN AND
RUNNING INTO A SYNAGOGUE,
RIGHT?
I WOULD CALL THAT IMMINENT
VIOLENCE, RIGHT?
>> Tucker: THAT'S NOT SPEECH
THAT'S VIOLENCE.
NOW YOU ARE REALLY SCARING
ME.
>> SO WE HAVE TO LIMIT
VIOLENCE.
I'M SAYING YOU LIMIT
VIOLENCE BY LIMITING.
>> Tucker: ELIMINATE SPEECH
AND ELIMINATING PRIVACY.
>> NO, COME ON.
>> Tucker: COME ON.
GIVE ME YOUR PASSWORD.
I WILL SEND YOU A TEXT AND